jane campion has apologized for her
quote thoughtless comment that she made
to serena and venus williams at sunday's
critics choice awards yeah so jane took
home best director for power of the dog
but her acceptance speech drew major
criticism as she pointed out the fact
she was the only woman nominated in her
category and then awkwardly singled out
the tennis superstars take a look
it's absolutely stunning to be here
tonight among so many incredible women
and venus and serena what an honor to be
in the room with you
[Applause]
i've taken up tennis
i truly have and will if you want to
come over and give me lessons
i would truly love it
i actually had to stop playing because i
got tennis elba and you know serena and
venus you are such marvels
however you do not play against the guys
like i have to
and people just and i know we cut it but
that room exploded into applause like
that that joke or whatever it was went
over very well in the room right it did
it went it went over very well in the
room uh okay so that comment quickly
sparked outrage online with many calling
her comment disrespectful unnecessary
and rude gina since apologized in a
statement to variety writing this i made
a thoughtless comment equating what i do
in the film world with all that serena
williams and venus williams have
achieved i did not intend to devalue
these two legendary black women and
world class athletes uh jane continued
the fact is the william sisters have
actually squared off against men on the
court and off and they have both raised
the bar and opened doors for what is
possible for women in this world the
last thing i would ever want to do is
minimize remarkable women i love serena
and venus their accomplishments are
titanic and inspiring serena and venus i
apologize and completely celebrate you
uh now venus and serena were in
attendance for king richard and have yet
to comment publicly on jane's comment
but i know and that's that initial
article from variety they had said that
they were all together at the netflix
after party on jane and venus and serena
doing pictures and whatnot so i don't
know whether they smooth things out
there and this is just for for everybody
else it was an unnecessary comment i
think it was more of a joke were sort of
to bring everybody together it was
unnecessary and i know people have said
this stuff before about the williams
sisters right um and i could understand
you even having these thoughts if they
were the type who were walking around
saying we could beat any man out there
they haven't not since they were
teenagers have they have they even had
that conversation about how they would
fare against men it's not part of their
world they don't sort of make a platform
about it but everybody just sort of goes
back to that thing and i think that this
with jane campion you know was a little
the film world tends to get their head
up their butts a little too deep during
award show season and so to compare the
sort of competitiveness
of what you do during award show season
winning something with what they do
okay it's it's like your head's a little
too far up there you're taking the
competition of the critics choice awards
a little too seriously when you even
start to
equate what that kind of competition is
like compared to what the williams
sisters do it was
she really fan girls for a long time yes
she does when she's up there uh talking
about tennis and talking about the
williams sisters and i can grant her
that it was like a a really poorly
thought out
joke or something in the moment where
she was nervous and said something
whatever uh in the room i'm sure it went
well we have people here that kind of
understand who said it here i saw a
great one carl just says
this went down like a fart in an
elevator outside of that award room and
the truth is like
once you leave the room
the whole world is going to see what you
just said and everyone's going to take
it for
you know what they feel and people are
very um
people understand the significance of
venus and serena williams yes in the
greater context even outside of the
sports world so i can understand people
being like yo like that was offside you
probably shouldn't have said that yes um
even though i do believe and especially
since her
very very well-written and worded
apology apology like i have no
belief in at all that she meant any
malice by anything at all especially if
you're watching that clip from the
beginning where she's like i took up
tennis because of you guys i love being
in the same room as you um but yeah
i i guess you just got to think
sometimes yeah before you say a thing
that you know that even if your
colleagues in the room are going to
laugh because it's a goofy joke and they
know that you're maybe goofy or not
great at telling jokes the rest of the
world is going to go yo wait yeah and
there's no way to say that without
diminishing their accomplishments
mcenroe when mcenroe said
john mcenroe was asked where the
williams sisters would rank um if if it
was just a global sort of ranking men
and women and he said 700
right and he got a lot of heat for it
but it's not that he was wrong it's just
that even answering that question will
always diminish their
achievements yeah it would it it always
will and again i have to they're not the
ones fighting for this it's everybody
else who has these conversations it's
not venus and serena who are in the
middle of these conversations but
there's no way to say and especially
with jane campion up there you know when
you say but you guys do you don't have
to face the men even a joke even a joke
and try and be like oh we're all in this
together and you're proud of me and i'm
proud of you and i love tennis and
everything else there's no way to even
say that without diminishing everything
that they've achieved a hundred percent
and that's the thing like how do you
even approach
that's why i'm wondering like what was
going through her head in the moment
yeah because how do you even approach
trying to make a joke like that when you
know what they've done outside of it
unless like you said in the beginning
all you're thinking is about yourself
what's going on with you yeah